I will suck I'm Brandy's brother hey
that hurts all of which we hustlers - oh
hell no damn motto we hired in a white
girl at an ATM concert getting
lightheaded
I need oxygens in a honey bun the Freak
got us up here with the third tier
groupies somebody gave me pregnant
tonight I don't care if it is clipper
death you see baby girl Alberta air yeah
I'm gonna make a tape with heart we
gotta get out of here I came to see dunk
by LeBron not ski spy-ray Jay P there go
three seats right there let's gank those
bitches come on man physically
unfortunate we can't sit there
yeah how you gonna talk your way into
that my mom said we sitting there I took
the bus here the driver let me honk the
horn
it went bit bent here's your
complimentary bibs and remember keep
your jewels off the floor and their dick
in your pants
enjoy the game this don't feel
right my dudes and my souls and
everything yeah I'm with Christ
damn y'all acting like bitch-ass
Minnesota House watch I'm gonna
touchable check this out oh it's okay
little fella
see y'all still think my idea was up
here I think I'm a bounce oh
Brad brothers coming our way
oh my god he touched me
I'll never jerk off with any other hand
again special gifts for our special
guest the law I see you if she niggard
in a snicker see y'all still trying to
bounce
hey kids I got something for you get the
shorts you get the drawers and uh don't
mind it like boo-boo static Dan you are
the king I love you the proud
what are you right thanks for keeping
your dick in your pants the other team
could have used you tonight watch
survivors remorse on Showtime I mean
stars your pal LeBron man ain't nobody
trying to watch that